[Music]  is in shock as a group of terrorists has  taken control of large areas of syria  and iran  the world can be a cruel and dangerous  place  remember  even if you're afraid  be strong  your loving mother  [Music]  fatima did your mother ever tell you the  story of the lady of heaven  [Music]  she was very special  daughter to the prophet muhammad  my time is near  and after with my lovely fatima  you will face many trials  with my father no longer here to lead us  evil is with those who will extinguish  the light of truth  god will judge all of you  lady fatima's goodness  inspired people to stand up  no matter what the cost  her legacy lives on  [Music]  you